d'un océan à l'autre cette devise bien
connue pourrait servir à décrire la
culture de la pomme de terre au Canada
mais si la patate est une vraie culture
nationale dans l'Ouest canadien elle
doit être irriguée ce qui n'était pas le
cas autrefois dans le climat maritime de
l'Île du Prince des doigts sauf que
là-bas les changements climatiques
forcent les agriculteurs à revoir leur
pratique
l'Île du Prince des doigts avec ses
paysages verts et sa terre rougeâtre est
aussi bien connu pour la blanche pomme
de terre
[Musique]
au Canada quand vous pensez pomme de
terre vous pensez à l'île du procédoir
est l'un des plus gros producteurs de
pommes de terre à Lille il a la capacité
de fournir les marchés canadiens et
américains 12 mois par année au menu
délivraisons la fameuse recette burbaine
Bros
la recette Burbank existe depuis 150 ans
c'est celle qui se conserve le mieux
c'est aussi la pomme de terre préférée
de consommateurs car elle fait les
meilleures frites elle a donc la plus
grande valeur marchande
comme toute pomme de terre est composée
de 20% de matières solides et de 80%
d'eau donc ce tubercule a besoin
d'arrosage régulier pour bien croître
mais à l'Île du Prince et doit l'eau
n'est pas omniprésente entourée de mer
salée il n'y a que quelques petits
rivières la principale source
d'approvisionnement en eau pour tous les
usages dont la grande agriculture
provient des nappes phréatiques qui
elles dépendent de la pluie pour se
réalimenter
il en faut peu mais au bon moment dans
un monde idéal on aurait besoin de 25 mm
depuis chaque semaine mais ce n'est pas
ce qu'on a bah oui dans
comme partout l'Île du Prince des douar
est frappée par les changements
climatiques et les productions de pommes
de terre risque d'en souffrir
il faut environ 120 jours entre la
plantation et la récolte
nous avons besoin de beaucoup de chance
en cette période de changement
climatique les températures sont
généralement de plus en plus chaudes
l'été et plus moins qu'avant
de plus en plus on entend les gens les
producteurs dire que les années sont
inhabituelles
[Applaudissements]
au bon moment et la récolte a été
exceptionnelle mais l'année d'avance
c'était la sécheresse juillet et où ont
été sec
dirige des études au tout nouveau centre
de recherche sur les changements
climatiques de l'Université de l'Île du
Prince Édouard grâce à plusieurs outils
de mesure dont des drones il veut bien
documenter l'évolution du climat faire
des prévisions hydrologiques et analyser
l'état des sols
nous avons plus de 70 stations
météorologiques sur l'île grâce aux
données qu'on y recueille on peut
calculer les réels besoin en eau des
cultures selon les conditions météo
est de déterminer quels sont les besoins
en eau des cultures et de les comparer à
ce que nous recevons comme précipitation
on peut ensuite calculer l'exact
quantité d'eau requises pour combler
l'écart s'il y en a un
notre centre veut développer des
stratégies capables d'assurer une
sécurité alimentaire malgré les
bouleversements courts
déterminer les mesures de mitigation qui
nous permettront de nous adapter au
changement climatique
au cours des 20 dernières années un
moratoire empêchait la construction de
nouveaux puits pour la grande
utilisation d'eau dans la province
c'était pour protéger les ressources en
eau
cela a été levé à l'été 2022 au grand
soulagement des agriculteurs mais les
écologistes eux sont inquiets
pour itazaz Farouk la variabilité des
précipitations devrait inciter les
agriculteurs à économiser l'eau et
surtout à développer des plans de
contingence
on pourrait récupérer l'eau de pluie et
créer des étangs de rétention dans les
zones de dépression on pourrait ensuite
pomper cette eau pour irriguer les
cultures il y a diverses
même si la moyenne annuelle de
précipitation est la même on a un
problème parce que les pluies n'arrivent
pas au moment où on en a besoin il faut
réfléchir à une façon de s'adapter
durant ces années anormales qui pourrait
bien devenir la nouvelle normalité
[Musique]
nous devons nous fier à la science et à
la recherche c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons ici car il fait de plus en
plus chaud l'été et de plus en plus
froid l'hiver
changer de variété de pommes de terre
fera peut-être partie de notre nouvelle
réalité certaines d'entre elles seront
plus résistantes à la sécheresse et les
scientifiques travaillent à les
améliorer les choses avancent en ce
moment pour nous aider à nous adapter au
changement climatique
[Musique]